>> Jimmy: BRIAN, WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MAN, YOU'RE A FANTASTIC ACTOR.
BUT I -- BEFORE WE GET INTO
YOUR WORK ON "SUCCESSION," I
WANT TO ASK, HOW WAS THE SUPER
BOWL COMMERCIAL?
>> IT WAS GREAT.
IT WAS -- YOU KNOW, IT WAS --
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT EVERY DAY
THAT YOU PLAY GOLF WITH
SERENA WILLIAMS.
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: NO, EXACTLY RIGHT.
YEAH, YOU WERE IN A MICHELOB
ULTRA SPOT.
HERE'S THIS.
>> OH, THERE WE ARE.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> Jimmy: SERENA SWINGING
THERE.
>> SHE WAS -- SERENA WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE SHE -- SHE
DOESN'T REALLY LIKE GOLF.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> AND -- YOU KNOW?
SO --
>> Jimmy: INTERESTING.
>> YEAH.
SO -- SO, SHE WAS -- YOU KNOW,
SHE WOULD -- I WOULD -- YOU
KNOW, SHE'S VERY CONTAINED, AND
SHE WAS DOING THE BALL, AND SHE
WOULD DO IT.
AND SHE GOES -- AND THEN THAT
WAS IN MIAMI WHERE WE FILMED
IT.
AND THEN LATER ON, WE CAME TO
PHOENIX TO WATCH THE GAME, TO
WATCH THE ACTUAL SUPER BOWL.
AND SHE WAS AMAZING BECAUSE
SHE'D BEEN PRACTICING.
AND SHE'D BEEN PRACTICING HER
SWING.
AND SHE WAS EXTRAORDINARY.
AND I THOUGHT, "YOU KNOW, YOU
ARE SO SECRETIVE."
>> Jimmy: YEAH, DOESN'T THAT
MAKE YOU A LITTLE MAD?
YOU GO, "CAN'T YOU BE -- YEAH,
YOU HAVE TO BE GOOD AT
EVERYTHING?
>> I KNOW.
YEAH.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> I'M GONNA GET CRAZY.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: YOU ACTUALLY GREW UP
NEAR ST. ANDREWS, RIGHT?
>> I DID, I DID, I DID.
>> Jimmy: WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> WELL, IT WAS -- IT WAS --
NO, IT WAS GREAT.
I MEAN, I SAW -- I MEAN,
FAMOUSLY, WHEN I WAS SEVEN, I
SAW BEN HOGAN --
>> Jimmy: WOW.
>> -- WIN THE CARNOUSTIE OPEN.
>> Jimmy: OH, MY GOSH.
>> AND I GOT -- I ACTUALLY HAD
A PHOTOGRAPH TAKEN WITH HIM.
AND PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO
BEN HOGAN IS.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
A LEGEND.
>> BUT YOU PROBABLY KNOW WHO HE
IS.
>> Jimmy: ABSOLUTELY KNOW WHO
HE IS.
BEN HOGAN IS THE GREATEST.
>> AND THAT WAS -- THAT WAS AN
AMAZING TIME.
BUT I'M NOT A GOLFER.
I'M HOPELESS.
I CAN'T DO IT FOR LOVE, NO
MONEY.
>> Jimmy: WELL, YOU -- WELL,
YOU HAVE TO BE A GOLFER,
THOUGH, IF YOU GREW UP NEXT TO
THE COURSE.
>> NO.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY YOU'RE
NOT A GOLFER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: YOU'RE LIKE, "YOU
DON'T HAVE A CHANCE AT IT."
>> WHEN YOU'RE NEXT TO THE
COURSE AND YOU ALL SEE THESE
GUYS DOING IT, THEY CAN GO,
"[ BLEEP ] THAT.
I'M NOT DOING THAT."
[ LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE ]
NOT FOR ALL THE TEA IN CHINA.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
YOU'RE SUCH A GREAT DRAMATIC
ACTOR.
BUT I WAS READING A COUPLE
INTERVIEWS, SO THAT YOU MIGHT
BE READY FOR A BREAK IN DRAMA
AND DO A LITTLE COMEDY.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: I WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> WELL, AS YOU GET OLDER, YOU
JUST WANT TO MAKE PEOPLE LAUGH.
I MEAN, WE LIVE IN THE MIDDLE
OF SUCH A BIG [ BLEEP ] SHOW,
IT'S -- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE LAUGH MORE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, AND I -- I THINK
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO DO.
I WANT TO LAUGH.
I WANT TO BE, YOU KNOW -- I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, LOGAN'S QUITE
FUNNY.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, HE IS.
I THINK HE'S VERY FUNNY.
>> YEAH, NO.
>> Jimmy: BUT YOU WERE IN ONE
OF MY FAVORITE COMEDIES, "SUPER
TROOPERS."
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Jimmy: THIS IS A CULT
CLASSIC NOW.
BUT I MEAN, FOR YOU TO BE IN
THIS WITH THE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
COME ON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RIGHT?
>> BROKEN LIZARD.
>> Jimmy: BROKEN LIZARD.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: JAY CHANDRASEKHAR.
>> JAY CHANDRASEKHAR, GREAT
DIRECTOR.
>> Jimmy: WHEN YOU --
FANTASTIC.
WHEN YOU GET OFFERED THIS ROLE,
DO YOU GO LIKE, "NO, WHAT'S
WRONG WITH YOU GUYS?"
>> NO, NO, NO.
NO, THE POINT IS I'M AN ACTOR.
I DO DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND THE MORE DIFFERENT, THE
BETTER.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> SO, WHEN SOMETHING LIKE THAT
COMES ALONG AND THEY SAY, "BUT
WHY DO YOU WANT TO DO THAT?
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO THAT?"
THAT'S IMMEDIATELY THE REASON
THAT YOU DO DO IT.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY SAYS, "WHY DO
YOU WANT TO DO THAT?"
I'M GOING TO DO IT.
THAT'S IT.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, YEAH.
YOU'VE TAUGHT ACTING OVER THE
YEARS.
AND THERE'S A RESURFACED VIDEO
THAT JUST SHOWING UP ON THE
INTERNET NOW WHERE YOU ARE
TEACHING SHAKESPEARE TO A
A 2-YEAR-OLD.
>> YEAH.
WELL --
>> Jimmy: WE HAVE A CLIP OF IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> TO BE.
>> OR NOT TO BE.
>> TO BE OR NOT TO BE.
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
>> YEAH.
IT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> FANTASTIC.
TO BE.
>> TO BE.
>> OR NOT TO BE.
>> THAT IS THE QUESTION.
>> YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Jimmy: COME ON!
IS THAT THE CUTEST THING?
WHAT A CUTE KID.
>> OH, HE'S AMAZING BOY.
AMAZING.
I MEAN, HE'S NOW -- THAT WAS --
HE'S NOW 13.
YOU KNOW, HE WAS AN AMAZING
KID.
HE IS AN AMAZING KID.
>> Jimmy: HOW CUTE.
AND YOU GO LIKE, "YEAH, THAT IS
THE QUESTION."
IT'S LIKE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YEAH, THAT IS THE QUESTION.
AND HE REALLY UNDERSTOOD.
YEAH, YEAH.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> HE UNDERSTOOD THE QUESTION,
YEAH.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
ARE YOU -- DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
ANYONE IF PRACTICED ENOUGH CAN
BE AN ACTOR?
>> YEAH.
I THINK ACTING IS -- YOU KNOW,
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT ACTING, IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT BEING AN ACTOR.
IT'S ABOUT BEING IN TOUCH WITH
YOURSELF BUT UNDERSTANDING WHO
YOU ARE.
AND THERE ARE NOT VERY MANY
INSTITUTIONS WHO DO THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST YOU.
THAT'S IT.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DEAL WITH.
AND IT'S -- YOU LEARN SO MUCH.
I MEAN, I -- WHEN I WENT TO
DRAMA SCHOOL, IT WAS THE BEST
YEARS OF MY LIFE BECAUSE IT
GAVE ME A VISION OF WHAT WAS
POSSIBLE.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, ALSO, EVEN IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING INTO ACTING, I
WOULD SAY IT'S PROBABLY GOOD.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Jimmy: IT GIVES YOU
CONFIDENCE.
>> YEAH.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ACTING.
IT'S ABOUT BEING A HUMAN BEING.
AND THAT'S -- THAT'S WHAT WE
DO.
THAT'S OUR JOB.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
YOU'VE ACTUALLY GONE VIRAL FOR
SOME OF YOUR OPINIONS ON METHOD
ACTING.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, JIMMY, I'VE
BEEN A LITTLE HARSH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, I HAVE.
NO, NO, CAREFUL, CAREFUL.
I HAVE BEEN A LITTLE HARSH ON
IT.
AND -- AND I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT.
AND IN FACT, I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT IN
A -- IN A MASTER CLASS SERIES
OF ACTING THAT I'VE JUST BEEN
DOING.
>> Jimmy: WELL, I DIDN'T KNOW
YOU DID A MASTER CLASS.
>> NO, I KNOW.
IT IS.
AND, YOU KNOW -- WELL, ACTUALLY
I BROUGHT A CLIP OF -- IF YOU
WANT TO SEE IT.
THIS IS A CLIP.
AND I THINK THIS MORE
ELOQUENTLY EXPLAINS MY FEELINGS
ABOUT ACTING.
CAN -- CAN YOU SHOW IT?
>> Jimmy: OF COURSE.
HERE'S A CLIP FROM BRIAN COX'S
MASTER CLASS.
♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HI.
I'M BRIAN COX, AND THIS IS MY
MASTER CLASS ON THE CRAFT OF
ACTING.
JUST [ BLEEP ] DO IT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
ACT!
SAY THE [ BLEEP ] LINES, AND
DON'T BUMP INTO THE [ BLEEP ]
FURNITURE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> Jimmy: THAT'S THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL THING.
THAT'S THE MOST BEAUTIFUL THING
I'VE EVER SEEN.
>> IT'S VERY BEAUTIFUL.
WELL, I'M -- EVEN WATCHING, I'M
QUITE MOVED BY IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: I NOTICED YOU DID
MOVE A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> Jimmy: YOU WERE OVER THERE,
AND NOW YOU'RE OVER HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE FINAL
SEASON OF "SUCCESSION."
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: BOY, OH, BOY, I FEEL
LIKE WE WANT MORE.
YOU KNOW, WE WANT -- WE WANT A
A COUPLE SEASONS MORE.
AND I THINK --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE'RE NOT READY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THERE'S AN
OLD ADAGE, "WHEN THE PARTY'S AT
THE BEST, LEAVE."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE.
YOU KNOW, JESSE ARMSTRONG, OUR
GREAT CREATOR, HE'S JUST -- YOU
KNOW, HE WON'T LET SOMETHING GO
PAST ITS SELL BY DATE.
HE KNOWS THAT TELEVISION ISN'T
INFINITE.
FOR HIM, IT'S FINITE.
SO -- AND EACH SEASON TOPS THE
LAST SEASON.
>> Jimmy: YES.
>> AND THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH YOU
CAN DO IN TOPPING THE SEASON.
SO, THIS SEASON IS THE TOPPER
OF ALL SEASONS.
AND ACTUALLY, INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH, HE HADN'T -- HE KIND OF
HINTED TO ME THAT HE WAS GOING
TO STOP.
THE SHOW WAS COMING TO AN END.
BUT HE DIDN'T REALLY DECIDE
UNTIL QUITE LATE ON.
IN FACT, I THINK
SARAH SNOOK --
>> Jimmy: YEAH, SHE WAS HERE
LAST NIGHT AND DIDN'T KNOW.
>> YEAH, SHE DIDN'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW, SHE DID THE LAST
EPISODE, AND SHE DIDN'T KNOW IT
WAS THE FINAL READING THAT THE
SHOW WAS OVER.
BUT THEN, SHE'S AUSTRALIAN.
SHE LIVES FAR AWAY, AND THEY
DON'T LISTEN VERY WELL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: DID YOU HAVE AN
INKLING THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE
THE LAST SEASON?
>> I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO BE
THE LAST SEASON.
>> Jimmy: YOU DID?
>> YEAH, I KNEW AND I, KIND OF,
FELT IT IN MY --
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> MY BONES.
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD
THING.
I DON'T MIND IT.
I LOVE ENDINGS.
I LOVE GETTING THE [ BLEEP ]
FINISHED WITH IT.
YOU KNOW?
AND -- BUT, YOU KNOW --
AND EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE -- I'M
AFRAID --
>> Jimmy: NO, NO.
YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE CAN LEAVE
IN TO BE HONEST.
YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I KNOW.
IT'S WHAT I CALL THE "LOGAN ROY
DISEASE."
AND I'VE BEEN AFFECTED BY IT.
AND IT'S MY WIFE WHO'S NEARLY
DIVORCING ME.
>> Jimmy: WELL, LOOK AT THAT --
I MEAN, YOU HAVE -- WHAT A
A GREAT CAST AS WELL.
WENT ON --
>> THEY'RE A GREAT CAST.
>> Jimmy: HERE'S YOU GUYS AT
THE RED CARPET.
ANY ONE OF YOUR KIDS, DO YOU
THINK, DESERVE ANYTHING?
>> NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEY DESERVE [ BLEEP ] ALL, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
[ LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Jimmy: I KNEW THAT BEFORE I
ASKED IT.
I FELT IT AS WELL.
>> BUT I -- YOU'RE CLEARLY VERY
INTELLIGENT.
>> Jimmy: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU'RE THE FIRST PERSON TO EVER
SAY THAT TO ME.
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: ARE YOU ACTING?
>> WHAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, YOU MEAN NOW?
>> Jimmy: YES.
>> JUST A TOUCH.
>> Jimmy: JUST A TOUCH.
YEAH, I THINK --
YEAH.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T SEEN THE
SHOW BEFORE WE SET UP THIS
SEASON, WHAT CAN WE SAY ABOUT
THIS SEASON ABOUT "SUCCESSION"?
>> IT'S A ROLLER COASTER.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, IT REALLY IS.
AND IT'S -- YOU KNOW, WE'RE
BRINGING EVERYTHING HOME TO
ROOST, AND IT TAKES TIME.
AND I THINK YOU'RE IN FOR --
YOU KNOW, WE -- AS I SAY, HE
CAPS EACH SEASON.
AND I THINK THIS SEASON'S GOING
TO BE A CAPPER.
>> Jimmy: THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
I WANT TO SHOW A CLIP.
HERE'S BRIAN COX IN
"SUCCESSION."
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> YOU GOOD?
>> UH-HUH.
>> IT'S NICE, HUH?
>> YEAH, LITTLE PIGGIES
STUFFING THEIR MOUTHS.
WHY IS EVERYBODY SO [ BLEEP ]
HAPPY?
>> YOU OKAY?
>> YEAH.
I GOT DONE A HUGE [ BLEEP ]
DEAL AT EXACTLY THE RIGHT TIME.
I GOT A -- PLUS BEERS.
I GOT THE ELECTION.
I GOT PLENTY ON MY PLATE.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, BRIAN COX,
EVERYBODY!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THE FOURTH AND FINAL SEASON OF
"SUCCESSION" PREMIERES ON HBO
THIS SUNDAY.